In order to use the backward Euler method to come up with an expression
for w at the n+1 step, we know that we're going to need an expression for w dot.
So that's the first thing we deal with. Beginning with our equation for the force of friction.
We know that the acceleration of the wheel depends on the force of friction
divided by the mass of the wheel.
So we plug in this expanded version of the equation for the force of friction
into the equation for w dot and of course the track b.
In the backward Euler method, it says that w at the n+1 step is equal to w at the n step
plus the step size times the change in w at the n+1 step.
Now that we have expression for w dot, we can plug into the proper location in the equation below.
If rewritten as the wheel slip to see here and here as 1-w at the n+1 step over v,
which of course is just an equivalent expression.
This gets rid of any explicit dependents on this.
Remember from what I said earlier that v here changes much more slowly than w.
We then specify which v we're referring to right here.
But if you were to be more clear, this is the subn+1.
There's a little bit of rearranging we can rewrite this equation for w n+1 as this equation right here.
The amazing slightly counter intuitive to rearrange things like this
since this expression looks maybe longer and more awkward than this one does.
Remember, however, that our initial request for w
was that it obey an equation of the form that I wrote up here.
We have a term with w subn+1 and then term with e to that value and also a constant.
All just added together equal in 0. That's exactly what we have down here now.
This makes our job very simple. Remember, we want to identify what c, d, f, and k are.
And now, we can just read them directly off of this equation.
In order to implement the backward Euler method and the code now,
all we have to do is translate the variables c, d, f, and k into code just like I've done right here.
The expression for w that the solver is going to output.
is equivalent to the one that we just found using the backward Euler method.
It's very simple since the solver has already established for this.
All we have to do is fill in the proper values for these variables.
In the introduction video, I didn't talk much about what the solver is actually doing.
So now just take a second to explain that.
It's implementing something called a Newton-Raphson method.
This is a method used for solving implicit equations that are not linear.
So it's a perfect fit for the situation that we are faced with right now.
Let's say I have a function like this green curve right here
for which I want to find the x value of a certain point.
Maybe for example I'd like to find the x value of this x intercept right here.
So the thing that we actually know about this point then is the y value, which is 0.
To use in Newton-Raphson method, I start by making a guess
at what the x value that appears to that y value is.
Maybe I guess the x coordinate that corresponds this blue line right here.
What the Newton-Raphson method does is it takes the slope of the line
tangent to the green curve at this point.
This may be that tangent line looks a little something like this
and extends that line down to the y value that we're interested in.
Now, the next x value that I will guess is going to be the point of that tangent line
intersects the x axis in this case then I will do the same thing for this point and so on and so forth.
And eventually, my results will converge to the actual point that I'm looking for.
This is a very effective method for solving implicit equations.
The general equation showing the movement from one guess to the next guess is shown right here.
We can specify this to deal with the situation we're looking at by using this equation right here.
And in fact, that's exactly what's written in the code in this expression for w_new.
Now that we understand how are solvers working, let's look at the plot we get.
What we have here is a series of plot that all depends on time.
First, we have position then car velocity then wheel velocity and then wheel slip.
The difference series shown by the different colors in each plot
represent different values for the magnitude of the breaking acceleration.
Fusing them really close in the different parts of the top graph, you'll be able to tell
that 70 m/s² is the blue line; 100 m/s² is the green line;
130 the red line; 160 the cyan line; and 190 the magenta line.
So we can see then how different braking accelerations affect these 4 different quantities.
Interestingly enough, it's the 130 m to second braking,
which is one of the middle values that makes the car stopped first.
When we slam on the brakes really hard which is shown at the magenta and cyan lines,
the wheel stopped rotating very quickly and see the wheel velocity was 0 right away.
However, in tandem with that, the wheel slip increases dramatically,
and the wheels are locked very early on.
As a result, the car velocity does not actually slid down much.
Of course, as we would expect, we just don't put the brakes on very hard like with the blue one
then the car does go a pretty far distance, and it actually does not come to stop it all
in the time that we've allowed; however, this is the great example of how slamming on your brakes
is not the most effective braking method.
Great job on this problem.